welcome back so now we're finally ready
to actually develop the calm and filter
the optimal full state estimator if our
system is observable so if I have a
linear system and the a and C matrices
are observable meaning this
observability matrix has rank N and
spans the state space then we can
develop an optimal full state estimator
that we can then combine with our full
state feedback controller and so I'm
going to draw the schematic of this and
then we're going to figure out what the
system should look like so the schematic
of our I'm going to call this my
estimator and I'm not even going to call
it a common filter until we optimize it
because the common filter is an optimal
estimator this is an estimator of the
full state according to this diagram
down here what we're going to do the
output is going to be X hat the full
state an estimate of the full state and
the inputs to this thing are my control
inputs u and my measurements Y so I
measure the system and I'm trying to
back out X but in addition I have to
know how I'm kicking the system so I can
disambiguate that effective of the input
so the inputs of my full state estimator
are U and Y and the output is X hat ok
and I'm going to write down what the
system is and then we're going to figure
out how to optimize it given that there
might be some disturbances and noise in
the system ok
so the first things first I'm just going
to write down the system of this
estimator this is itself a dynamical
system a linear dynamical system so I'm
going to say that this X hat state DDT
of X hat and I'm just going to write
this down DDT of X hat is going to equal
a of X hat ok and then the inputs I've
got this U and Y so I'm going to have
plus B U and Plus remember how I had
that gain matrix for my lqr I'm also
going to have a game
matrix for my filter or my estimator so
k sub s for calm and filter I'm going to
have some constant matrix K and I'm also
going to find this using the solution to
a riccati equation times y minus y hat
okay and you might ask what is y hat
well Y hat is just this output equation
on X hat instead of on X so it's just
equal to C times X hat okay so this has
not been motivated yet I'm just writing
this down so it looks a lot like the
dynamical system for X so the dynamical
system for X hat looks a lot like the
dynamical system for X except every time
I get a new measurement I'm going to
compare it to what I think that
measurement should be and then if I have
a difference here I'm going to correct
my full state so this is essentially an
update based on new measurements on new
data Y ok so as I get new measurements
in Y this is going to correct my full
state estimate of X hat ok
and so I want to work this out a little
bit more so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take this expression and I'm
going to plug it into here and we're
going to see what DDT of X hat really
equals ok so let's just do this DDT of x
hat equals what is it equal well a times
X hat plus B times u plus KF y minus KF
Y hat but Y hat is C times X hat so
minus KF C times X hat ok now just a
super cool what we're going to have here
is I'm going to move this over and I'm
going to get this equals a minus K
a s C times X hat so this should look a
lot like the full state feedback
equation right I'm going to try to
change the eigenvalues of this by
choosing my filter games plus now I'm
going to write this in the following way
I'm going to say that this is B KF times
u Y okay so these are kind of like the
inputs to my full state estimator U and
Y are the inputs to my estimator so this
is my input matrix kind of my new B
matrix for this system and this is the
dynamics these are the dynamics of X hat
and what we want to do is we want to
make these dynamics stable and I'm going
to show you in a minute
that if these dynamics are stable then X
hat will stabili converge to X okay very
cool and it should start looking a lot
like the lqr full state feedback problem
if aliens see our observable now then
with an appropriate choice of K this
calm and filter gain matrix I can place
the eigenvalues of this anywhere I want
and there will be an optimal choice okay
so that's where we're going okay let me
now show you how you would actually
compute the error of this it's a little
bit messy but I think we can do it okay
so let's define an error epsilon equals
what is epsilon equal it equals my full
state X minus X hat now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to compute DDT of
epsilon and I'm going to show that it
has these dynamics I want epsilon to go
to zero so if I choose these to have
stable dynamics epsilon goes to 0 okay
this is a little bit involved let's go
through it okay and I'm going to carve
out a little bit of space here
hopefully it's enough so DDT of epsilon
equals D DT of X minus D D T of X hat ok
what's D DT of X we'll just this stuff
so that equals ax plus bu minus all of
this stuff right so minus ax hat plus
KFC X hat minus KF y plus minus B u ok
so right off the bat a couple things
happen so right off the bat my B use
cancel that's pretty great ok and now I
have an ax and an ax hat and I have a
KFC X hat and a KF y ok and so this is
ok great so we're getting super close so
we have four terms left this term this
term this term in this term for epsilon
dot my error dot so let's now say that y
equals C times X ok so now I have a
times X minus X hat a times X minus X
hat plus K F y equals C X so I have C
times X hat minus X ok I'm just taking
these four terms I plug in C X here and
this is what I get
so now let's flip the sign of this okay
and make this
let's make this X minus X hat and put
our negative sign here and now lo and
behold what we have is d DT of epsilon
equals a minus K FC times X minus X hat
what's X minus X hat is Epsilon okay so
what does this tell us this tells us
that this error between my full state my
true full state and my estimated full
state can be made stable and go to zero
if my system is observable so remember
it's observable if OBS D then I can make
this as stable as I want then I can
place the eggs by choosing K F and I
mean I could actually literally use the
lqr command if I wanted to or the place
command with a and C transpose and I
could design this gate that I could
determine this gain matrix for a given
set of eigen values that I want this to
have but the upshot is if my system is
observable I can build this dynamical
system with the inputs u and y they will
stable converge to the full state of the
system right I can make this epsilon go
to 0 by making these eigen values stable
ok so the next thing we're going to do
we're going to see well again why would
I not want this to be as stable as
possible and move my eigen values as far
into the left half-plane as possible
well in reality I have measurement noise
I'm going to have plus noise maybe n is
a bad variable let's call this sometimes
I call this w sub n these are some
measurement noise and maybe up here it's
really plus some disturbance to my state
ok so maybe I have I have some additive
WN that gets added to my measurement and
maybe my sister
actually has some disturbance so my
system is getting kicked i have
measurement noise and so we're going to
figure out what is the optimal k at the
optimal calming filter games to find the
optimal eigenvalues of this system given
some knowledge about the magnitude of
disturbances and the magnitude of sensor
noise and that's how calm and filters
are going to be developed okay thank you